chine après les arrestations les
premières condamnations à morts 3
manifestants condamnés à mort à shanghai
8 à pékin pour le gouvernement le retour
à l'ordre passent par la peur l'appareil
de l'état n'est pas épargné le
secrétaire général du pc à audience
qualifiée de modérée officiellement
dénoncée en france la condition
pénitentiaire n'est pas la même partout
et pour tous à strasbourg les détenus
disposent d'un lycée derrière les
barreaux enquête dans ce journal
la salle drouot-montaigne à paris est en
passe de concurrencer les plus grands
sotheby's christie's en ce moment même
une vente aux enchères robots plus de 80
toiles des plus grands maîtres de
picasso a2a minc à gauguin vers 20h20
nous irons faire un tour dans la salle
entière voilà monsieur bonsoir les
dirigeants chinois sont prêts à faire
payer le prix fort à ceux qui ont cru
pendant quelques semaines à la liberté
que celle ci était envisageable
après les arrestations par milliers
vient donc le temps des premières
condamnations à mort trois à shanghai et
8 aujourd'hui à pékin les coupables
qualifiés de bandits sont accusés
d'avoir manifesté voler ou incendier des
biens publics pendant le mois de mai
implacable la politique du retour à
l'ordre passent également par
l'épuration au plus haut sommet de
l'appareil de l'état
aosia secrétaire général du pc qualifiée
de modérée est officiellement désigné du
doigt
bref pour l'équipe qui a repris en main
les rênes du pays
il faut que l'ordre règne et pour y
parvenir il faut rétablir la peur
reportage de bruno le dreff et christian
c'est lors du journal télévisé que l'on
a appris ces huit nouvelles
condamnations à mort
cet homme et une femme accusée d'avoir
frappé des soldats et incendié des
véhicules militaires
il s'agit de paysans d'ouvriers et de
chômeurs déjà condamné pour divers
activités illégales
insiste le commentateur chinois comme à
shanghai il y a deux jours on remarque
qu'une figure parmi eux aucun étudiant
pour l'instant c'est donc sur les
classes populaires que s'exerce le plus
durement la répression chaque jour la
télévision chinoise montrent de
nouvelles arrestations
ces jeunes ne sont pas non plus des
étudiants ils subissent la position de
l'avion très en vogue à l'époque de la
révolution culturelle pendant deux
heures chaque soir les chinois subissent
ce matraquage idéologique tout en noir
et blanc les mauvais
contre-révolutionnaires et les bons
soldats de l'armée populaire de
libération
ils viennent aider à la construction
d'un immeuble participer à la moisson
nettoyer les rues il faut les aimer car
ils sont aimables sont les piliers du
pouvoir place tienanmen 24 heures sur 24
dans un garde à vous impeccable
kalachnikov serré contre la poitrine
ils font passer un même et unique
message pékinois vivait tranquille
l'armée veille sur vous elle veille
aussi à interdire toute image
aujourd'hui
les chinois veulent rétablir l'ordre
entre eux
dans les rues le risque des banderoles
qui exhorte le peuple a une attitude
révolutionnaire sur les murs les
affiches gouvernementale invitant à la
délation ont remplacé les écrits de ceux
qui réclamaient la démocratie
les journaux présente les photos de 21
dirigeants étudiants
quatre d'entre eux ont déjà été arrêtés
mais les plus importants ont pour
l'instant réussi à échapper à la police
et aux dénonciations
dans le même temps le porte parole du
gouvernement chinois déclare qu'on
ouvrira un dialogue sur les réformes
dès que la situation dans le pays sera
stabilisée des promesses apparemment peu
écoutés par les intéressés
depuis plusieurs jours le service des
visas de l'ambassade des états unis est
très fréquenté de nombreux étudiants
cherchent à quitter le pays sous couvert
de compléter leur formation ailleurs
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de chinois
le rêve de liberté a changé de continent
le problème des minorités ressurgit on
le sait déjà en union soviétique mais ce
phénomène de société des années 80
dépasse les frontières de l'urss pour
toucher certains pays de l'est
exemple ce soir la bulgarie qui se
débarrasse en quelque sorte de minorité
turque pourtant intégré depuis très
longtemps dans ce pays derrière cet
exode on trouve des raisons économiques
mais aussi religieuse thierry calmont le
village de toile se transforme peu à peu
en camps de réfugiés déjà trente mille
turcs se sont enfuis de bulgarie il
arrive à la frontière entre les deux
pays au rythme de quatre mille par jour
à la fin juillet probablement cent mille
d'entre eux auront échoué ici 1971
suppression de l'enseignement de la
langue turque en bulgarie et depuis le
26 mai dernier
sophie a mis en oeuvre une politique
d'assimilation forcée de la minorité
turque minorité forte d'environ un
million de personnes bulgare isation des
patronymes et surtout affaiblissement de
la culture islamique
raison de cet exode forcé la bulgarie
crainte d'une flambée de l'intégrisme
musulman
en turquie on se sent blessée par ce qui
est considéré comme une atteinte à la
dignité du peuple turc
le premier ministre monsieur turgut ozal
vient de visiter des camps de capi cool
et des récoles accueil enthousiaste de
ceux qui souvent foulent le sol de leur
mère patrie pour la première fois un
projet de naturalisation des nouveaux
immigrants a été adoptée et le
gouvernement d'ankara prétend que cette
arrivée massive de populations ne posera
pas de graves problèmes économiques et
le premier ministre turc en a profité
pour rappeler à l'ordre les occidentaux
près je cite à défendre les baleines et
a critiqué les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme en turquie et qui ne font rien
contre l'exode qu'elles sont forcés 1
millions de tubes et son côté la
bulgarie refuse toute discussion sur un
rapatriement négocier et citoyen bulgare
d'origine pur la terre a de nouveau
tremblé dans le nord de l'arménie une
légère secousse qui n'a pas fait
heureusement de victimes ni de dégâts
matériels dans la région qui avait été
dévasté
cette et en décembre dernier l'actualité
de ce samedi a été également marquée par
un accident d'avion sur l'aéroport de
berlin est en bout de piste à un
iliouchine en partance pour moscou a
pris feu bilan 5 morts et 13 blessés
l'évacuation a pu être mené heureusement
assez rapidement il avait ce talent est
plus apprécié et a décollé lorsque tout
à coup l'appareil s'est cassé
il a pris feu il n'y a pas eu de panique
les gens évacués dans le calme jour avec
soin
comme cet homme la plupart des passagers
ont pu échapper aux flammes
mais au moins cinq personnes n'ont pas
eu cette chance de l'iliouchine 62
il ne reste que ces morceaux de tôle
calcinée l'appareil parfait pour moscou
les réservoirs de kérosène pour une
raison encore inconnue
il n'a pas réussi à décoller en vous
piste il a terminé sa course dans un
champ avant de prendre feu en deux
minutes deux cents pompiers étaient sur
place mais il aura fallu plus d'une
heure pour maîtriser l'incendié
cinq morts et 13 blessés graves le bilan
pourrait s'alourdir car ce soir 19
passagers seraient portés manquants 113
personnes allemande soviétique italien
ce n'est pas les avaient embarqué à bord
de cette iliouchine-62 dans les avions
transport les plus utilisés
dans les pays du globe c'est dans un
appareil de ce type aient sur ce même
aéroport que 156 personnes avaient été
tuées en août 72
l'avion avait explosé à la suite d'un
incendie
en france la tension persiste dans
certaines prisons les familles de
détenus distribué des tracts cet après
midi devant la maison d'arrêt de fleury
mérogis et ce soir dans les prisons de
lyon et de grenoble plus de 200 détenus
refusent de regagner leur cellule
la période de l'été est toujours
difficile pour les prisonniers est par
ailleurs ils sont mécontents cette année
des mesures de grâce décidée par le
président de la république à l'occasion
du 14 juillet les estiment trop
restrictive puisqu'elle se limite à 9
mois maximum de réduction de peine dans
ce contexte nous vous présentons ce soir
une réalisation qui montre que malgré
des situations très différentes selon
les établissements pénitentiaires en
france des initiatives sont prises pour
permettre aux détenus de se réinsérer
ainsi à strasbourg les prisonniers ont
leur lycée derrière les barreaux en
quête de chantal kimmerlin et bernie
mériaux
oui
8h15 du matin sortie de la cellule à 316
maurice et christophe reynes quatre fois
par jour ce même chemin pour tous les
deux condamnés pour drogue ce n'est pas
le chemin du bail ni même d'un travail
en atelier si celui du lycée d'alice est
comme un autre d'un vrai lit ces
histoires français maths anglais
allemand physiques en tout par semaine
et combien d'heures de cours tranquille
une trentaine ça dépend 30 32
vous voulez passer quasiment alors un
diplôme d'entrée à l'université
c'est à dire une équivalence du bac et
une remise à niveau en comptabilité du
nouveau plan comptable programme interne
à la prison sur câble spécial écoles
anne hausse des cours et des examens
dans chaque cellule une aile et réservés
huit heures par jour ou des tenues
étudiants pas un uniforme
ici c'est la microcirculation ou presque
le maître des lieux l'éducation
nationale ceux qui encadrent les profs
venus des collèges lycées ou fac de la
région un proviseur elle même à
l'origine du lycée un conseil des
maîtres
le tout pour cent cinquante étudiants le
plus petit lycée de france mais bien
différent des autres
toute la journée et pour moi les
difficultés que je rencontre sont les
difficultés de lob de l'enseignement
c'est à dire arriver à trouver la
pédagogie adaptée à ses élèves disons
c'est à dire des adultes ce n'est pas
forcément une pédagogie qu'on pratique
dans un lycée de praticiens de la
traditionnelle non plus pour un essai on
n'est plus ici à l'âge de l'école
obligatoire et seulement 10% des détenus
s'inscrit tout court
vous devrez pouces et plus les gens
aller en cours sûr que les gens qui font
rien ou qui restent devant la télé à
longueur de journée tous un amour répond
en fait la différence entre les lycées
en prison et les détenus qui rompt pas
au lycée de la prison ça se voit us a
sans doute à son c'est pas le même c'est
pas le même état d'esprit
pas facile de réussir le pari d'un ici
en prison
introduire derrière les barreaux des
ordinateurs des calculatrices la gestion
des entreprises les langues étrangères
la poésie ou les livres qui font mal est
un droit de l'homme libre rien n'est
évident pour tous ils doivent se
remettre en cause quotidiennement
gardien profs ou des coûts du support
très certainement pas l'incompétence
sont demandeurs d'une compétence pour
arriver à les faire travailler
il faut que nous on soit irréprochable à
ce niveau là ce que je trouve tout à
fait normal ça ça me paraît normal
ensuite il faut inventer un autre mode
relationnel
en général ils réagissent comment vous
surveillants quand vous leur demandez de
vous et du lycée certains lui jalousent
certains nous envie
certains apprécient d'autres nous
haïssent l'éventail est large sa micro
cause m'en fait la prison reflète le
monde le monde tel qu'il est autre
difficulté que maurice n'ignore pas pour
aller au lycée en prison il faut pouvoir
se le payer donc je serai amené à
travailler en atelier comme le font la
plupart des gens qui n'ont pas d'argent
ou qu'ils n'ont pas de visites de la
famille et ses relations totalement
exploité cette semaine au lycée de la
prison de strasbourg présente ses
premiers candidats au bac et au bepc
l'année dernière au lycée de la prison
de fresnes sur quatre candidats au bac 4
furent reçus dont deux avec mention bien
le salon de l'industrie aéronautique du
bourget ferme ses portes demain dimanche
deux vedettes aujourd'hui le premier
ministre michel rocard en visite et la
navette spatiale soviétique bouran qui
est reparti vers moscou reportage de
laurent boussier et didier da tempête de
neige dans le ciel du bourget ou burhan
la navette soviétique perchée sur
l'antonov 225 envol de présentation
devant michel rocard et son invité le
premier ministre australien bob hawke
passage devant les tribunes et
applaudissements de la foule pour cet
attelage de 600 tonnes qui a besoin de
trente deux roues pour se poser
contraste saisissant entre le vol lent
du plus gros avion du monde et les
évolutions acrobatiques des avions de
combat rafale mirage 2000 et autres
mig-29 pour michel rocard cette visite
au salon du bourget a été l'occasion
d'insister sur la capacité d'innovation
de la france sur sa volonté de
coopération et surtout sur la formidable
reprise des marchés d'avions civils ceux
ci n'ont jamais été aussi importants
l'essor du transport aérien puis au
progrès économique au développement des
échanges et à la baisse des coûts de
transport créée en effet des conditions
exceptionnelles aujourd'hui pour le
marché des avions de transport des
avions qui se vendent bien comme la
terre 42 ou atr 72 avions de transport
régionaux franco italien comme le falcon
900 de dassault où l'airbus a320 qui un
an après sa mise en service commerciale
vient de passer la barre des 500
commandes fermes
commentaire d'un industriel qui a
déjeuné à midi non loin de michel rocard
heureusement que les ventes de matériel
civiles augmentent
elle compense à peine la baisse des
marchés militaires
les électeurs européens choisissent
demain leurs députés au parlement de
strasbourg à la veille de ce scrutin est
bien l'espagne ça rime encore un peu
plus à la communauté
en effet la monnaie espagnol le pesetas
rejoint le serpent monétaire européen
explications de claire chazal un grand
jour pour carlos solchaga le ministre
des finances espagnole
il s'agit de la décision la plus
importante depuis notre adhésion à la
cee en janvier 86 at il déclaré
aujourd'hui à madrid
concrètement la paix êtes la monnaie
spagnol ne pourra plus fluctuer
librement
elle devra s'en tenir à une valeur
donnée et ne pourra s'en éloigner que de
6% en plus ou en moins comme la lire
italienne des règles certes contraignant
pour les autorités espagnoles qui
devront surveiller de très près
l'inflation et les grands équilibres
économiques pour éviter un dérapage de
la monnaie
mais felipe gonzalez le chef du
gouvernement les accepte car il sait que
l'espagne rentre ainsi un an plus tôt
que prévu dans le cercle des pays les
plus développés de l'europe elle est le
neuvième pays à adhérer au sm le système
monétaire européen la grèce et le
portugal n'en font pas encore partie
pas plus d'ailleurs que la grande
bretagne qui refuse toujours de perdre
son indépendance et de favoriser l'union
monétaire du 12 pour la rectification
dit bien des pesetas semer un pcet
l'innovation en france pour ce scrutin
de demain dimanche les 55000 non voyants
français ont obtenu de voter en toute
liberté je m'explique leurs bulletins de
vote seront écrits en braille reportage
de marc maisonneuve et philippe mon
choisy le suffrage est universel égal et
secret
cette phrase est extraite de l'article 3
de notre constitution
pourtant les aveugles devaient jusqu'à
présent voter par procuration 1 ou 3
voter pour eux les laissant parfois
supposer
ce vote là n'était pas tout à fait le
leur je voter par procuration mais un
moment donné
sur les votes j'ai eu un petit doute ça
m'a fait reculer un peu
demain pour l'europe les 20000 aveugle
français qui lisent le braille pourront
voter comme tous les autres sur des
listes traduite pour eux ils
identifieront le candidat de leur choix
pour la première fois les institutions
du pays prenne conscience que les
aveugles ont une écriture clé le braille
et qu' il faut les concernés dans leur
écriture
alors pour l'instant c'est au stade
expérimental vraiment ce que je veux
c'est que ça c'est l'expérience soit
fini et que ce soit classique parce
qu'on a besoin de ça mais ça c'est qu'un
début sur les maisons d'ambition c'est
que un aveugle puisse recevoir chez lui
sa note de téléphone en braille sa note
d'électricité en braille et toutes ses
factures en boîte
excusez moi je veux dire on paye comme
n'importe qui il est important que on
est la facture dans notre écriture
puisque c'est notre écriture
il y à 55000 aveugle en france eux aussi
ont le droit de vivre pleinement les
règles de la vie démocratique
à la veille de cette élection européenne
comme il ne nous est plus permis de
parler politique l'idée nous est venue
de retourner dans un village de 500
habitants du puy de dôme à saint-andré
le coq il y a un an et demi et bien ce
village a été désigné géographiquement
mathématiquement comme le centre de la
communauté européenne
d'abord incrédule les villageois ont
ensuite décidé de profiter de cette
aubaine
et aujourd'hui ils ont bien changé ils
ont des idées même si l'argent manque
quelquefois reportage de dominique
verdeilhan et jean-françois big athènes
est à 2800 km
madrid 12 100 kg mais londres 850 en son
centre géographique l'europe des 12
paraît parfois bien lointaine de
saint-andré nos coqs
c'est à tomber comme ça mais je crois
pas que ça représente grand chose ici
l'europe des pieds vincent de le
renvoyer en plus d'étrangers les deux
berges hollande aller on change dans la
rue on tombe sur des anglais c'est tout
pour l'instant sa portée les reconnu
c'est tout et aucune retombée
nicotiniques et myriam il ya un petit
peu de gens de passage qui est de voir
une borne un drapeau à 12 étoiles d'or
seule marque visible d'une empreinte
européenne dans un village de 500
habitants qui a enfin retrouvé un café 3
qui est un marché à prendre mais faut
pas trop trop attardé mais je crois que
les premières années y'a pas de raison
sur tout bon en ce moment et c'est plein
boom l'europe c'est l'europe
je suis allée curieux ils sont 28 19 sec
faire de saint-andré un haut lieu
touristique c'est l'ambition de la
municipalité prête à vendre un de ses
terrains pour permettre l'implantation
d'une sculpture d'un site d'observation
et d'une salle polyvalente
quand il y aurait déjà un point
d'attraction un pôle d'attraction ici je
contacterai des ambassades des
différents pays pour voir si vraiment
chaque pays intéressé à avoir un magasin
ici qui vendrait ses produits
symboliquement au centre d'europe
un projet de 7 millions de francs que
saint-andré ne peut assurer seule sans
les 12 mai durant la campagne électorale
un seul candidat s'est rendu au centre
de l'europe
il faudrait que certains fans aux
parlementaires s'y intéresse un peu de
plus près mais je trinque
le 18 juin passé on retombe encore dans
les oubliettes autres hantise au village
l'europe des 13 ce jour-là saint-andré
le coq cessera de se prendre pour le
nombril de l'europe
on l'a vu tout à l'heure les chinois
sont appelés à la délation pour la
mauvaise cause dénoncé ceux qui ont
manifesté pour plus de liberté dans leur
pays la comparaison est tentante avec
cette émission de télévision américaines
qui elle propose de dénoncer à priori
pour une cause plus juste retrouver les
coupables de crimes et délits qui n'ont
jamais été résolus par la police
américaine
les réussites sont nombreuses la
dernière en date l'arrestation d'un
homme qui il y a dix huit ans de cela
avait assassiné toute sa famille de new
york notre correspondant ponam
l'histoire de cet homme est
extraordinaire arrêté il ya quelques
jours par les big eyes john list et est
le criminel le plus recherché en 1971
dans l'état du new jersey il assassine
ses trois enfants sa femme et sa mère
puis disparaît sans laisser la moindre
trace
john list change d'identité se remarie
et va vivre paisiblement dans l'état de
virginie
toutes les polices abandonne les
recherches sauf un détective james
maurane aujourd'hui à la retraite depuis
18 ans james maurane est sur la piste du
criminels qu'il traque en amérique du
sud en asie et en europe mais l'ancien
policier ne perd pas espoir il veut
avant de mourir arrêtez john list
il y a deux semaines dans sa maison du
new-jersey jones maurane a une toute
dernière idée il va confier toute la
sphère à une station de télévision par
câble qui possède une émission célèbre
intitulé l'homme le plus recherché des
états unis une émission regardée chaque
dimanche soir par 20 millions de
téléspectateurs
le principe en est très simple si au
cours de l'émission vous croyez
reconnaître le coupable ou si vous
possédez le moindre indice vous appelez
la police en pcv
voici le générique de cette émission
aux états unis on assiste à un crime
tous les quarts d'heure la police est
débordée les prisons sont pleines
mais dans le cas de john lice comment le
retrouvait 18 ans après qu'il ait commis
ces cinq assassinats avec des comédiens
des réelles témoin de la faire
l'émission va reconstituer le drame et
producteur de l'émission font même appel
à un artiste qui sculptent le visage de
l'assassin tel qu'il devrait être
aujourd'hui j'ai rarement vu une
émission de télévision aussi utile c'est
l'intérêt de la société que ce genre de
personnage soit arrêté il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il a tué cinq personnes au
cours de l'émission la police a reçu 300
appels des appels confidentielles qui
ont conduit à l'arrestation de john list
depuis sa création il ya deux ans ce
programme de télévision aura permis la
localisation de 48 grands criminels tous
repris par la police
en amérique la population collabore très
volontiers avec les forces de l'ordre
sans problème de conscience
prochaine émission dimanche prochain
retour en france la galerie
drouot-montaigne à paris est devenue la
plaque tournante des ventes d'art en
europe elle est en passe même de
rattraper les sables célèbre pardon
christie's ou sotheby's depuis 19h30 ce
soir plus de 80 toiles de maîtres de
duffy à picasso en passant par chirico
de vlaeminck gauguin sont mises aux
enchères dans la salle maintenant je
vous propose de nous tourner en direct
vers cette salle drouot montaigne
nous nous retrouvons georges bigot
exemple ont discrètement à la manière de
ce qui se présente ce futur de
télévision faire trop de bruit
la vente se passe à ce moment que les
duels directs sous volet millions 6 à
gosselies tarragona l'enchère ici
l'étude à monsieur un million alors
vient d'être adjugée de vlaeminck un
million six cent cinquante mille
c'était un tableau paysage de 1912 1913
et nous nous retrouvons maintenant
devant une toile de maurice utrillo qui
sous la direction de maître francis
brille est re va être estimée aux
environs de 400 milles à 6 en mieux nous
sommes dans cette simple deux roues
teigne andrew martyn qui a été installé
depuis un an et qui permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir un marché de l'art français qui
se portent très bien
d'autant plus que nous sommes sur le
plan européen aujourd'hui certainement
le marché qui est le plus favorable
grâce aux droits d'enregistrement qui
ont baissé de 5%
et il faut dire en malgré tout que dans
l'assemblée nous avons beaucoup plus
d'étrangers que de français beaucoup
d'américains notamment beaucoup de
espagnols qui se sont déplacés car
l'airé beaucoup de thalie à vendre via
mais dali malgré son décès la cote de
dali n'a pas considérablement augmenté
si vous le voulez et syrah ou semblables
bien je vais vous montrer deux petits
coups de marteau enregistré juste avant
que nous le prenions l'antenne il y
avait un superbe et marans
voilà qui a été attribué à 620 milles
francs et ensuite le num ou de dali qui
est montée jusqu'à 1 min nous revenons
en direct dans la salle au moment où on
amène main sur le cheval est un max
ernst
nous débutons à 600 milles pour le
numéro 39 s'agit d'une aquarelle de 1900
ambiance est feutrée nous parlons un peu
comme à roland garros il simule cela un
débutant est nécessaire bien entendu 800
mille cent vingt mille six cent
cinquante mille six cent cinquante mille
six cent quatre-vingt mille sept juges
680 mille sept cent mille c'est un livre
coûte rien et il est déjà sept cent
vingt mille sept cent cinquante mille
huit cent mille huit cent mille nous
sommes il y aura un cent mille tout au
long du mois de juin
c'est encore des banques seraient très
importantes ducrocq montaigne d'adp juge
huit cent vingt mille huit cent
cinquante mille huit cent cinquante
mille en voulez-vous 870 1900 milles
vous voyez les téléphones 900 me
fonctionne avec tous les pays étrangers
qui donne les marges ou 900 qui passent
leur commande dans un miror 950 milles
non franc non en 950 milles par
christiane juge de 950 ville pas le
regard à droite ni à gauche plaide juge
à voulangis roissy dans 150 mille très
bien acheter un max ernst dans la coque
ne cesse de monter et voici un jeu angry
ce je pense qu'on va terminer avec ce
tableau jeu un registre très belles
oeuvres 500 milles pour le numéro 40
compotier vert de 1916 1600000 1 million
700 mille un million sept cent mais nous
sommes un million huit cent mille 1
million 900 me restera là ce soir bien
qu'à un million huit cent mille pour ce
tableau je pense que c'était passionnant
à regarder mais leur tour on va passer
aux sports maintenant avant les
compétitions l'histoire d'abord d'un
athlète antoine richard champion de
france du 100 m espoirs de l'athlétisme
français ça c'était en 1987
victime d'un contrôle antidopage hills
était soignée avec un médicament
interdit pour soulager un genou
déficient il fut alors condamné à deux
années de suspension cet après-midi en
banlieue parisienne à livry gargan
eh bien c'était son retour à la
compétition reportage de dominique le
glou et andré germes et mossu
retrouvailles hésitations d'un pied qui
caresse à nouveau la fils envie de
balayer les fantômes du passé compagne
qui a vécu une semaine difficile
entraîneur qui a vécu lui deux années
terribles mais le plus dur c'est antoine
qui l'a connu suspendu deux ans coupable
sans être responsable
priver du plaisir de la compétition
angoisse du retour sueurs froides peur
de rester bloqué dans les startings du
dopage et une faute bon une
responsabilité quelque part mais c'est
une chose
on est vraiment sûr c'est que ce n'est
pas de la faute d'antoine c'est vraiment
lui qui a subi les conséquences
c'est sûr ce n'est pas de sa faute alors
bruno mcdaniels gilles des relayeurs du
4 x 100 m sont toujours resté à ses
côtés pendant ces deux ans ils ne l'ont
jamais laissé tomber et c'est là où dans
les épreuves difficiles où l'on compte
ses amis il a pu en compter deux très
solides les amitiés sur la piste les
invités sur la piste mais au bout de la
ligne droite il a laissé sa nouvelle
passion son futur métier ses ambitions
la photo sportive en course il n'a rien
perdu de sa technique et de sa
motivation
il seconde 67 centièmes encourageantes
certes il lui manque 15 mètres deux ans
de compétition mais le retour d'antoine
pour lui c'est un peu comme lens 0-1
tête et commence tard temps là qu'ils
avaient sous les mains bon c'était du
pur tartan tout cela semble hélas et
j'ai remis les pieds en compétition
j'avais un peu le trac au départ mais ça
s'est bien passé en définitive rassurer
heureux comme un petit roi richard est
impatient de retrouver sa couronne ses
cinq titres de champion de france et son
record qui tient tous du nom 10 secondes
9 centièmes dans deux ans il n'y aura
plus que 18 équipes au lieu de 20 dans
le championnat de france de première
division de football la décision a été
prise cet après-midi par la ligue
nationale de football pour tenter de
relever le niveau général du football
franz grand prix du canada de formule 1
le français alain prost a réussi pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
saison
un meilleur temps que son coéquipier
ayrton senna aux essais après son succès
au grand prix des états unis le champion
français a visiblement retrouvé la
grande forme
ce n'est pas le cas il faut le dire des
trois écuries françaises engagées en
formule 1 cette saison et qui
connaissent déception sur déboires de
montréal notre envoyé spécial lionel
chamoulaud
l'année dernière aucune écurie française
n'a marqué le moindre point au
championnat du monde cette saison n'est
pour l'instant guère plus brillante mais
curieusement c'est l'équipe la plus
modeste à gs qui réussit le mieux car
qui nie le remplaçant de streiff a
marqué un point à mexico au grand
soulagement d'un ricochet le nouveau
patron de l'écurie
la voiture est bonne bien que ce soit
celle de l'année dernière elle a évolué
sur un plan aérodynamique et elle a une
autre qualité c'est qu'elle est très
fiable ce qui procure ces très bons
résultats un point marxistes sont des
soucis en moins et pour le moment guy
ligier on a des soucis ces voitures
bleues n'ont pas de résultats à phoenix
aucune d'entre elles n'était au départ
les préqualifications guette la doyenne
des équipes françaises sa bio tourments
il envoie sa partie au moment où le
matin vous savez vous avez une heure
pour requalifier pour pour le grand prix
sar après de passer ça veut dire qu'il
faudra encore des gens complémentaires
beaucoup plus de travail sur la voiture
de développement pour mieux connaître la
voiture du côté des larousse aucun point
inscrit non plus et aucun grand plus
terminé malgré tout gérard larrousse
froid au potentiel de son équipe
j'ai choisi une politique à risque en
prenant une voiture nouvelle d'un moteur
nouveau une boîte de vitesses aussi et
je crois qu'il faut savoir assumer ces
moments difficiles et surtout pas perdre
confiance elles forment première chose à
faire
il reste encore trois courts aux écuries
françaises tourves était dans le peloton
de tête de la formule 1 le temps presse
et le temps ne traîne ne presque plus
pour les chevaux puisque le tiercé le
quarté sont arrivés cet après midi vous
allez voir les résultats s'inscrire sur
votre écran pour gagner il fallait jouer
le 7 le 5 et le 14 p'tit tiercé pour ce
qui concerne le quarté vous ajoutez le
15 mai ce n'est pas très cher payé non
plus voilà ce journal est terminé de
suite après les prévisions météo avec
josé dans la pierre aux alentours de
zéro heure philippe gassot après le
spécial champs-elysées consacrée à yves
montand et puis ensuite vous chaussez
vos lunettes noires pour une nuit
blanche vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bien entendu et
je vous dis à demain 13h en soi
à